can people follow along with this test
that we're going to do oh yeah you want
to do this yeah sure let's do the test
yeah so um
psychos and let's find out if you're a
psycho and you're a psycho people can
follow up follow up with this test uh
they can they can play along as we go do
we need to make notes on our phones yeah
what are you going to need you're gonna
need a piece of paper or a mobile phone
uh because what you're gonna what you're
going to do is you're going to score I'm
going to read you out 11 items okay 11
simple items and these items all
hypothetically describe you as a person
okay and what you're gonna do you are
going to score each item according to
how accurate a description you think
this is of you okay and you're going to
do it according to the following scoring
key okay so four point scale that going
from zero to three okay if you strongly
disagree that the statement describes
you strongly disagree give yourself zero
right if you disagree
give yourself one if you agree give
yourself two and if you strongly agree
give yourself free so it goes from zero
strongly disagree one disagree two agree
three strongly agree okay and I'm gonna
read through them you're going to score
it as we go along right
number one
I rarely plan ahead I'm a spur of the
moment kind of person I rarely plan
ahead I'm a spur of the moment kind of
person so zero strongly disagree just to
recap one disagree two agree three
strongly agree number two
cheating on your partner is okay so long
as you don't get caught
now whenever I do this with students in
universities in large numbers this is
always the one where people are looking
over their shoulders think what the
other person said uh cheating on the
point is okay as long as you don't get
caught number three
uh if something better comes along
it's okay to cancel a long-standing
appointment
something better comes along it's okay
to cancel a long-standing appointment
number four
seeing an animal injured or in pain
doesn't bother me in the slightest
number five driving fast cars riding
roller coasters and skydiving appeal to
me
number six it doesn't matter to me if I
have to step on others to get what I
want
number seven I'm very persuasive I have
a talent for getting other people to do
what I want
number eight I'd be good in a dangerous
job because I can make my mind up
quickly
don't think too long about that one
uh number nine
I find it easy to keep it together when
others are cracking under pressure
number ten if you're able to con someone
hey that's their problem they deserve it
and a final one number 11 most of the
time when things go wrong somebody
else's fault not mine don't pin it on me
right so 11 items you should have 11
numbers on a page there gentlemen I want
you to top that up and come to a grand
total don't say what it is yet
got the total there Francis not yet okay
I can see why you never got the job on
countdown mate
you got yours confident in got yours
Francis all right now I'm going to go
through for the folks at home
I'm going to go through what this the
little key on the Spectrum so you can
see where you score
what we should say at this point is
we're not diagnosing anyone here all
right this is just a general indication
of where you are on the psychopathic
Spectrum it's quite accurate but it's
just not we're not diagnosing right zero
to eleven
you are low on the psychopathic Spectrum
have either of you scored zero to eleven
no no no all right okay
right 12 to 17 you are below average on
the psychopathic Spectrum you're the
first now what did you score I scored
17. 17 that's on the high end of that
that's the that's the border between
below average and average which is 18 to
22 which is me oh you're in there okay
what are you 19. 19. I surprised myself
massively oh do you know what I think P
I think with Piers Morgan 18 or 19 I
think peers might have been 18 or 19.
well I'm more Psychopathic than Piers
Jesus [ __ ] Christ I think you might
be one point higher so agents went 18 to
22 is average uh 12 average your average
yeah yeah you can feel the tension
rising in here 23 or you would do anyway
if people are playing on at home
um it'd be interesting people send their
scores in actually I don't know yeah we
can do and people can post their scores
on our locals and also maybe what they
do for a living would be quite good yeah
so 18 22 is average 23 to 28 is high and
29 to 33 which is obviously quite rare
is very high
[Music]